Margeaux what's bothering you the movies  coming out in a few weeks and everyone's  talking about how it's a squad full of  bad guys but there's more to it than  that  you know facade is they're actually  really friendly and we have a leader  with tremendous accuracy no joke this  must be crazy teammates who many would  consider unstoppable I mean absolute  monsters interest does the squad bend  the rules sometimes sure  seriously the hell's wrong with you  people for bad guys but that's something  because they want to win and what's  wrong with winning huh I totally get it  haters give my squad a hard time too you  really get me wrong your squad my squad  we can party grog style so crazy  I want to assemble a task force of the  most dangerous people on the planet  they're bad guys worst of the worst  but